[upbeat electronic music]
- We've all been there.
It's your first trip
to New York City,
and you've got your perfect
Times Square selfie
all lined up.
And your big melon takes up
the whole photo.
Fail.
What to do?
- I'll tell you what.
You need the original
Selfie-Stick.
- Get in here, you guys.
[music continues]
This thing is great, but
my arm's getting really tired,
and I wish I didn't have
to hold it up the whole time.
- Got you covered, girlfriend.
Take a gander at the new
hands-free Selfie-Stick.
- Hands-free?
- That's right. With this, you
won't have to hold it at all.
- Awesome!
[grunts]
- Now you're in total control.
- It's really,
really up my butt.
- Sure is.
- Try it!
- Using it is easy.
When you want to take a picture,
just clench.
- Um...
- I love it.
I never leave home without it.
- Smile!
- Why?
- So you look cute
in the picture!
- It takes pictures?
How?
[grunts]
Oh, that's how.
[music continues]
- [grunts]
- Free up your creativity...
with the original
hands-free Selfie-Stick.
- It's the best!
- I can barely feel it anymore.
- Smile!
[music continues]
- [grunts]